is that what it
push we both have it on our devices so I
that all
set real
good okay good afternoon everyone we're
going to open this division 3 house find
work session scheduled for 1:00 today in
the calendar and posted outside the door
on Senate Bill
499 that's relative to reduction of
hunger for children older adults and
people with
disabilities so just to sort of give the
landscape here before we begin I am
representative Moren money of meramac
the vice chair of division 3 I'm sitting
in as the chair for this work session
and also the work session 2 o' uh absent
today is representative Edwards and also
representative
walner uh in place of Representative
Edwards is representative Lon welcome
back and thank you thank you and then
we'll head right into the history of
Senate bill for
99 so looking back at the docket Senate
Bill
499 was in the Senate Health and Human
Services committee it came out of that
committee 5 to0 came out of then the
Senate finance committee 7 to0 came out
of the Senate with an a to pass with
Amendment on a Voice
vote when it came to the house it was
actually vacated by the chairman of the
House Education committee on a Voice
vote on March 28th so when this bill
came over it was offered essentially to
the house education committee as I read
the docket it was um
vacated and then it came directly to
finance and then here to division
three last week there was a joint
meeting between divisions two which
oversees the education portion of the
budget and division three and we met for
probably a little over an hour on House
Bill 499 uh taking in very helpful
testimony on those that were interested
and those that had
information after that meeting
there was an understanding that division
two would meet separately on the
education portion of this
bill because it is in two parts it's a
education piece and then there is a
elderly Affairs
piece
um it was decided division two would
meet on the education piece and division
three would meet on the elderly Affairs
piece a subsequent to that meeting the
division 2 meeting did not take place as
I understand there was agreement that
they they would not meet I don't know
the the details fully but that's what
happened so now here we are at our
scheduled time on Senate Bill
499 uh we may recall uh the meeting the
work session from last week and it was
of very detailed and there's a lot to
this bill in terms of both cost
uh the fiscal note in various categories
the policy contained within about the
different programs being proposed it is
complexed and now it comes to us who
will give a recommendation our job today
is to give a recommendation for the full
finance committee house finance
committee to take a vote on uh
incidentally too I just want to mention
that all bills all of these bills have
to be out by May 16th so here we are
with that background and um the
understanding uh of what occurred since
our last meeting does anyone want to say
anything or add anything to anything
I've said representative
tarki I don't know if this would be a a
question for you as the sitting chair or
the chair of Finance but how is this
actually going to work in terms of each
division um coming out with a
recommendation and
then how we bring it to the full
committee do you have any Clarity on
that they split the bill up and so
division 2 is going to bring their piece
of it and then division three will bring
their piece of it and we'll vote on them
separately similar to like divide the
question on the floor yeah okay so can I
ask a question though on that sure
procedurally one of clarification are
you sure about that yeah that's my
understanding was different education
committee had passed P passed it off to
us no we're talking about division two
and division division two division two
sorry they're going to make make
recommendations it's going to be on the
on the calendar we're going to vote on
with two different
pieces okay but they've already amended
it so in effect we're voting on
amendments right but it's a single Bill
and as I think represent tki was
pointing out if it's going to be two
different pieces it needs to be split on
the floor correct cor no if
if what I was informed of first is the
amendment was going to eliminate the
first half and then we'll have the
second half in another amendment and
that's what will be probably come before
the full committee okay so can you
actually clarify that a little further
about the first half of the bill so we
can understand where we're at and so the
people in the audience will understand
what happened to the first half of the
bill well a couple of things on that um
I don't know if division 2 has plans
before the 15th or before we meet as a
full house finance committee to meet
again on this bill that I do not know
and I think that goes to a huge part of
your question um I know that the bill is
in our possession I also know that uh we
can start the discussion right away
leading to what representative Wier was
talking about an amendment is going to
be proposed that uh representative
Edwards has organized
with regards to the second half of the
bill so why don't we distribute that
Amendment now if we could Mr
Ripple so this is amendment
2024 hyphen
H and I'm familiar enough with it uh in
a meeting I had with representative
okay I while everyone is reviewing it
this is um essentially what the
amendment
does in the
bill as we
start with the Human Service section so
that's on page three section four line
six
there is a provision in
here that would
simplify the elderly Snap
application for participating in the
elderly simplified application project
with the supplemental nutrition
assistance
program there was discussion that this
is a critical piece of the bill because
it uh would allow those who access this
application
to not have to continuously reapply
which has become quite cumbersome and it
sounds like that's rather urgent in
terms of uh this particular section of
the
bill so the amendment before you would
replace the entire
bill with just that
portion with just that section four on
page three
uh the appropriation then would be the
sum of
$37,500
ending uh fiscal year June 30th
2025 in order to streamline that
application
process uh for those that need that
elderly simplified
application so
that is the uh
Amendment essentially addressing
the division three part of this
bill and uh again you'll notice that it
replaces the entire bill so as for the
division 2 portion or the education
portion uh that would not be included in
version representative priest uh thank
you for taking my question again for
clarification you're basically uh
striking out all the bill that relates
to school age children and disabilities
and replacing this that just pertains to
the
elderly
correct representative
Stringham so the HHS portion of the bill
had two specific sections that we were
to address uh one one of which appears
unchanged which is um the change of uh
eligibility or
requalification uh for the snap program
the
$37,500 is consistent with the figure
that we were told uh would be needed to
implement that and in fact we were told
that uh because of reduced paperwork and
so on with people not having to
re-qualify
uh we may end up
actually finding that to be way to even
much more money we may actually save
money in the long run by having a
three-year versus a one-year
requalification so what is taken out so
really what this bill is is not about
this part which is the same as the
original Bill and uh was passed
unanimously in the Senate but what this
takes out is the whole summer
um EBT
program uh the EBT program provides um
uh some supplemental funds for for uh
children in need over the summer at the
rate of I think $10 a week uh that loads
onto a card um the the money for running
that part of the program uh comes from a
federal federal government but the money
that we would need to appropriate is uh
putting in the infrastructure necessary
for us to be able to implement that
program which was something like
$780,000 or maybe slightly less than
that
uh
um so um but in in that ballpark so I I
really think the discussion for us as
division 3 ought to be about the EBT
program and whether that's something
that um we want to match the Senate and
support or whether whether uh it's the
position uh the recommendation that we
would make to the full committee uh to
jettison that so if we don't want to
jettison it then we just um don't accept
this amendment I vote down this
amendment assuming it's even introduced
I think right now we're just discussing
it it's not formally being being done uh
the other thing you're talking about I'm
a little confused of how the doe part of
it would get get put back into the bill
my guess is that they would amend this
amendment uh and put back in all all the
elements of the first section when they
meet or we do it at full finance
committee somehow this this thing has
bill has to get put back together if
it's torn apart in sections so uh in
terms of the EBT program you know I
thought it sounded pretty reasonable
and um uh and you know I was inclined to
support it so um uh you know in in
general I don't think this particular
amendments uh need needs to be put
forward but that's I'll just throw that
started thank you for that and that does
lead to further clarification so section
four of the bill page three begins on
line six
however there are two paragraphs there
one does relate to Summer EBT the other
to the elderly simplified application
this amendment
165h is only including the elderly
simplified application part of section 4
Senate Bill 499 representative
hle sure thank you so I'm looking at the
fiscal note for this and I believe I
heard testimony relative to all the
sections of this bill that were not
funded with General funds or were funded
at a single dollar that the department
could of Ed could not Implement those
policies during that and I grant granted
that section of the bill is is over with
division too but I do believe we heard
that none of those policies could be
implemented because we did not fund
those in this
bill this question is either for the
chair for Mr Ripple right the
$499 right the reduced lunch that was
still during the academic year correct
that was not during the summer that's
correct yes so I don't believe there was
any funding for the summer EBT cards in
this program
correct there is funding for the summer
EBT program it's an open warrant to HHS
in the language currently and that's
thank you yeah and that was estimated at
about 1.1 million in fiscal
representative
wer when we first went through the bill
there were a lot of loose ends because
the uh School launch program now is
basically funded mostly by the federal
funds up to 185% of poverty this was
going to go much further they didn't
give us a good count of how many people
that would involve I look in my notes I
don't see anybody identifying a number
and I don't see it in the fiscal note of
It's kind kind of open-ended
and why why are we deciding that this
whole new group needs to be funded and
at that point there would be no federal
help because they would only help up to
185% then anything we want to do above
that we're on our own and it would all
be State funds from education trust fund
or wherever and do we really have that
big a hunga problem in this state that I
don't think they properly Pro such
things nor could they put a number on it
nor could they and then some of these
things like after the Bell so there are
some children that must be having a a
free
breakfast and then there's other
children that come in after the bell and
and that whole arrangement of who was
going to what what was the type of food
was it going to be in a refrigerator
were they going to pick it up going down
the hall to the to the home room or how
was it going to work out and that wasn't
carefully thought out was it going to be
warm was it going to be cold could
anybody just grab it on the way uh you
weren't really picking out who could
take it and who couldn't unless you want
to have employees everywhere to make
sure the right people got the right food
and it just seemed to needlessly
complicate everything without really
spelling out how it would be done it
just seemed like it wasn't a
well-developed bill at one
point the chairman of division 2 said
this sounds like it needs to go to
interim study and uh he was he was
pretty sure there was as was I there was
a lot of loose end
and I don't think he wanted to move
forward with what he had anyway that was
that was why we thought of all right
there is one good piece in here that's
taking the one-year renewal to two
three-year renewal and that's worth
keeping and that's basically what the
amendment
does representative tarki thank you very
much Madam chair with all respect to
Chairman Wier um the section that this
division is supposed to address has
nothing to do with the school lunch
program during the school year that was
the division
2's um focus our focus is solely on
summer EBT which has nothing to do with
the Department of Education and division
2 and the simplified elderly application
now with that I'm wondering if it's
possible to have New Hampshire hunger
Solutions uh perhaps come and help us
understand a little bit I was chatting
with um M milikin uh last week
about how some of this um what's left in
the bill what we're looking at and
exactly what it is that's that we're
looking at and how it's funded is there
order but would you mind if I just
recognized representative Leon prior to
recognizing thank you Lon thank you
madam chair um sorry that I'm just
jumping into this and I wasn't in your
PR previous meetings but I know in my
town in Dair there's several locations
where they offer the lunches during the
summer um to children and those who
qualify for them with the summer EBT
program replac that so that instead of
having those lunches available um at the
fairways and other locations it would
EBT representative tki um those summer
program prrs are um often times uh
nonprofits and not affiliated with
DHHS um the summer school program has a
lunch program for those students who are
enrolled in summer school that's
different summer EBT as I'm sure someone
could help um Enlighten us with more
specifics is simply um an additional
SNAP program that families would receive
for children who qualify for the
month okay thank you for that all right
Miss
milikin hello good afternoon um I did do
um a a one pager on uh sumary EBT I also
included the elderly simplified
so one of the things that I think is a
bit confusing is that there are um
several Federal programs that um provide
options for schools and community- based
programs to feed kids in the summer uh
and summary BT is a new federal
program um it's a much more direct way
of ensuring that children who are um
under 185% of poverty can access meals
in the summer it's
just uh
$40 per child per month in the summer
months so it's $120 per child per summer
and it comes to the family on an EBT
card just like snap that can only be
used to buy
food so that's um that's how summer EBT
works there are some some some schools
offer programs in the summer um for
families to be able to send their
children to programs and they would get
uh meals while they're there those are
um and those are great where they are
but they're not everywhere um there
really um are lots of gaps across the
state and many times families can't get
their children to this the place where
the where the meals are being provided
so it's just a much more direct way of
making sure that children are not hungry
in the summer children who during the
year eat free and reduce meals um would
would get additional dollars on the EBT
card so that they would not be hungry
the summer and just to be clear on the
cost um I I will defer of course to uh
my colleague at DHS but I believe they
testified that most of the cost is a
one-time cost um just under uh $900,000
or one-time cost for the electronic
changes that need to be made in their
system um and the ongoing cost is is
much lower um under $300,000 a year and
just the benefits for children for
families are 100% Federal so this would
be bringing quite a lot of federal
dollars into the state and I've provided
some
estimates um on the sheet that I handed
out
so representative Lon uh thank you madam
chair and thank you for that information
um so the summer food food service
program with the USDA is what we have in
my town if a family was had that would
they also then get these additional EBT
benefits where they're getting federally
funded meals in one location and then
also getting these additional EBT
dollars they could they could um they
could get both it's I mean and just to
be clear it's $40 per child per
month um the EBT so um I don't you know
money representative wer so family at
this income level is also qualified for
food stamps are they
not uh yes that's right and doesn't the
food stamp provide for each
child well um food
stamps the average payment for food
stamps for a meal doesn't cover the
average cost of an actual meal in any
County in New Hampshire I'm I'm happy to
provide you with those data but um while
snap is incredibly helpful to families
it's generally not enough to meet their
needs most families run out of of uh
SNAP benefits you know by the second or
third week of the
month so it's incredibly helpful to
families to be able to have their
children eat breakfast and lunch at
school during the year and during the
summer the federal government has
created this new program to ensure that
they can access food in the summer as
well it seems like we're duplicating all
this Administration when an increase in
one would have taken care of it rather
than having two or three other programs
because the town will have a program
snap will have a program food stamps has
a
program it just seemed to if you
increased one place then it would all be
centralized and we wouldn't have so much
money of the program spent on
Administration I would love to see
families have one program that met all
their needs that would be lovely but
unfortunately those are the funding
streams are what they are so the federal
government has has uh provided these
funding streams and um to my mind it
doesn't make sense not to use them to to
feed hungry kids um it's a lot of
federal dollars that would be brought
into the state uh about 4 and a half
million the return on investment is just
like snap it's invested in the local
economy so it stimulates the local
economies um and
if this bill doesn't pass uh the
department has testified that they're
not going to be able to participate in
the program for this year and also for
next year um so you know those are
federal dollars that will be left on the
table okay we're going to go
representative tersi then priest then
hle thank you madam chair thank you Miss
Milligan for being here and helping us
break some of this down can you just
clarify that I'm reading this correctly
that your data shows there are
37,325 children living in poverty that
would qualify for this that potentially
don't have enough money for food that
number is is from the Department of
Education that's how many children are
currently enrolled in free and reduced
meals so that's who would be eligible
for this for for the summer program
yes thank
you thank you Mr uh Miss chairman and
thank you for being here um my first
question was addressed um by your
response about the 37,000 children that
would qualify for the summer EBT do you
also have a number of the elderly and
people with disabilities in which this
program in its original state would
benefit so the the elderly simplified
application project um would uh make it
easier for older adults and people with
disabilities who who have no earned
income who have fixed incomes um to
qualify for snap I don't have exact
numbers of how many people it would help
I have some estimates um which I've
included um but I would say that
currently uh participation in snap by
older adults um in New Hampshire is
we're we're the third lowest in the
country for uh participation so
um you know in thinking about this bill
that the sponsors really wanted to do
something that would encourage older
adults to be able to access the benefits
for thank thank you um so we heard
earlier from Mr Ripple that this is a
$1.6 million cost and I'm not sure I'm
understanding how the federal government
is going to be putting in the 4.5
million monly or your estimated 4.5
million and then the state's going to
have to pick up some portion but the
notes I see look like it's 50% of the
administrative cost and I just can't
reconcile those numbers so can you help
there um again I certainly would defer
to my colleagues at DHHS but I but I
would say that um that what they have
estimated for
fy2 is
1.57 U million um and of those um
890,000 are one-time cost the ongoing
cost is for 20 26 is
2595 and for 27 is
2655 um and that's that's for both
that's for the summer EBT and it
includes uh the eldely simplified
application project follow follow up do
we or Mr Ripple do we have updated
information on the financial side of
this in terms of estimated costs no and
I don't believe that's I don't believe
the numbers from HHS have changed um
okay
but but but that information is correct
the one time the administrated costs are
funded 50/50 between the state and the
federal government okay um at a $1.1
million first year cost in about 200
somewhat thousand in subsequent years
but then the benefits themselves are
funded no further
question okay anything further for miss
milikin anything
further all right thank you very much
very informative and I know you've spent
a lot of time and effort on this Bill
thank you representative Hall yes since
we've been discussing an amendment I'd
like to at least move the amendment for
the purpose of disc discussion of 2024
165h which is representative Edward's
amendment to modifying the bill for the
purpose of least having a discussion
about it now and is that seconded I will
second okay G have representative f as
the recorded second would you like to
speak to your motion representative hle
sure so I understand that there is
potentially a lot of money that the
federal government um might have
available and I emphasize the word might
relative to this presentation by New
Hampshire hunger Solutions however the
federal government is very broke right
now so counting on somebody who's very
broke to continue to write checks is is
a fraught Mission I do think we should
try and fix some of the things relative
to our elderly populations and make sure
that they can continue for a longer
period of time without having to
reenroll and that cost of the $37,000
likely will be something that could
potentially be a savings to the state in
terms of administrative costs which
means a higher percentage of the
benefits go to those we trying to help
and not to just covering overhead so
with that I'd like to move to the
amendment okay the motion is the
adoption of 1650 which was um described
and discussed earlier representative
Hall's motion any further discussion on
the motion of the adoption of the
amendment representative tarki thank you
very much Madam chair um I will not be
able to support the me Amendment for a
number of reasons let me
start number one I am still entirely
confused as to the process of dividing
up a bill um the way I'm interpreting
this regardless of what the intentions
are of division 2 and division three and
whatever conversations were had from
those two chairs this one little piece
of paper is going to completely throw
away the rest of the bill including the
parts that we were not um allowed to
discuss so for that reason alone I
cannot um support the amendment
because I do believe there is important
valuable information that we have not
really dug into um it's the purview of
division 2
um second to that is I believe that the
new federal summer EBT program is
something that would be valuable to
37,000 329 children in this state that
don't have enough to eat at home for
whatever reason if it's parents who are
underemployed if it's children who live
in unique family situations with
grandparents with guardians um these are
children that due to no fault of their
own do not have healthy food in their
kitchen cabinets and not enough of it
and I think that for this division to
throw out an
opportunity for a relatively small
investment from the state state to
enable this opportunity to bring that
extra benefit to families who are
struggling is is really unfortunate so I
will be voting against this amendment
with the hopes of um saving part of the
original bill and I hope my colleagues
me representative
priest I will also be voting against
this amendment I think Mike I'm sorry
um I will also be uh voting against this
amendment because the fact that it's
gutting the entire bill that's been
coming over here from the Senate and I
live in an area the city of Manchester
and I see this all the time when I'm
doing walks in the neighborhood of the N
the amount of poverty um that's in
Manchester and when you consider that
almost 40% of the children in Manchester
is in this group your heart kind of
breaks and the fact that um this is a
very low amount of money that we're
asking for from the state um to provide
healthy foods for the children to get
them through the summer months and um
and secondly I think 37,000 is is
nothing to even address the elderly and
the people with handicap uh and their
food needs so with those two reasons I
amendment representative hle thank you
madam chair um I agree that it's
important to feed these families my
church is over in Auburn we have a food
Ministry meets multiple times a week we
funnel hundreds of thousands of pounds
of food into the Manchester area every
week well every year not every week I
also understand that our national
government is broken in terms of debt to
quote Albert Einstein compound interest
is the eth wonder of the world he who
understands it earns it he who doesn't
pays it we are at 37 and sorry $ 34.5
trillion in debt and by September we'll
be at 35 trillion we are at a point in
the fiscal world where we will run a
ground financially every time we say the
federal government funds something we're
counting on a check that we can't
guarantee and we have to be prudent
about this are we as a state willing to
write this check for the full amount of
this money because if you're making a
promise somebody has to write the check
at the end of the day and right now we
are far more solvent we New Hampshire
than the federal
government a large portion of our
government of our state is funded by the
federal government but in in in general
principles we have a much better credit
rating we are much better in terms of
fiscal sanity
are we about to agree to approving the
entire funding of this because the
federal government doesn't have it
this okay any further discussion
representative Stringham and we're on
the motion of adoption amendment number
165h which would replace the entirety of
Senate Bill 499 representative Stringham
yeah I'd like to ask my colleagues to
vote this down because uh on a process
basis as well as the other reasons
that's discussed uh division 2 has not
uh met to discuss this I understand the
chair of division 2 has problems with
the thing with the items under the doe
portion uh our working plan was that we
were going to split into two groups come
back together and then uh at that point
if the bill needed to be amended we
would amend it uh as as uh either the
two divisions together or perhaps the
entire finance committee uh to in
division three when we haven't uh
meaningfully discussed any of the doe
portion or the more significant portion
really of this bill uh that there was a
lot of work done um
uh uh I I I think risks the entire
process of of doing what we can uh for
those who are food um uh food short here
in in the State uh with with a a
programs with a lot of work done on them
that may work out very very well for us
so um uh my suggestion on the on a more
productive P process is just discuss
these two elements uh that are in the
HHS portion uh we can have an idea of
where we want to go it's obvious that uh
the extension to the three-year piece is
is uh unanimously supported and uh there
are um uh there are pros and cons on the
other the EBT portion of the
bill we walk out of here with with a
Resolute idea of where where we want to
go and wait till we remet with uh
division 2 or uh should our chair decide
There's A Better Way perhaps a full
committee uh to meet to to go through
after division 2 has met uh that we do
at this point but to just
discard uh uh all those different
sections of the do doe piece just
because some parts of it sounds like
it's messy and uh it might not be ready
uh should go to interim study or
something like that and just discard it
uh for the rest of this banum I think is
um uh shortsighted so I'm going to vote
against this amendment and recommend
that we just talk through and prepare uh
for the for the next session that the um
you representative tki I would just like
to say one last
thing from my colleagues on division
2 I'm pretty sure they have no idea that
this happened they do know that their
meeting was canceled today and I have a
real problem with the members of
division of a division not being allowed
to have a say over a policy that's been
put to them and have someone else pull
the rug out from underneath them so to
not allow those members to even be here
be part of this discussion and to know
that it's happening is just wrong and
I'm really sort of embarrassed that this
is actually even happening right now
thank
you okay the motion is made by
representative hle seconded by
representative Earth on the amendment
number 20 2014 1650
h no further discussion let's call the
ready so this is a uh uh the motion is
um uh in favor of the amendment the
amendment is
1650 um put forward by representative
hle seconded by representative
F and um
uh we'll start with uh representative F
yes representative hle yes
representative Wier
yes uh Representative
tersi
no representative Stringham says no uh
representative priest
no um uh representative Leon
yes and chairman Mooney
yes okay and representative walner being
absent the final vote is
1650 okay as a reminder we are making
recommendations to the Full House
finance committee that is our purpose
today uh at this point now we have a
motion of an amendment that's just
passed to replace the bill uh do we have
a recommendation motion at this point
representative H I move that we
recommend passage as amended to the
finance committee second so that would
be an ought to pass an
otpa to the finance committee with the
discussion represent tarki I'm just
going to say again for the record I am
really unclear how we even got to this
point I am uncomfortable with the way
this has played out and um I will be
voting no I think it's shameful that we
are throwing the whole thing away and um
we did not actually have a proper
process to even get to this point please
no representative Stringham yeah I just
if anybody uh here um uh can clarify
will division 2 be meeting between now
in the full finance committee meeting to
discuss their portion of this
know I don't know so I I intend to vote
no because I think the rest of the bill
need needs uh the kind of oversight that
uh that the hard work done in the Senate
entitles it to and the importance for
the um potential recipients of the
representa priest thank you um Madame
chairman I will also be voting no as to
the reasons that have been expressed by
my colleagues here about the process of
how we have come to this point and the
fact that we are gunning this entire
piece of legislation that's been worked
on carefully by the Senate and replacing
it with a
$30,000 allotment which doesn't really
meet the needs of the 100 approximate
100,000 people and
37,000 children that um are in this
poverty State and are needing SNAP
benefits and I just think it's inhumane
and maybe it's just my values but I
think it's
you okay representative hle are you I
okay this point the motion on the floor
is ought to pass with Amendment
representative hall for discussion yeah
um I understand and hear the argument
that it's
inhumane do not feed people but you
cannot be generous with somebody else's
money there is a fundamental philosophy
difference being generous means taking
it out of your own
account donating food helping with those
directly you cannot compel someone else
to be generous that's no longer
generous I hear your argument but what
we are doing is is requiring other
taxpayers to foot the bill when we do
this it is not about generosity at this
point generosity starts when it comes
out of your own biggy
Bank
okay we we cannot compel someone else to
fund
this okay representative Lon um thank
you madam chair um I recognize that this
first section is a division 2 issue
however we do need to recognize that
this whole part is about providing lunch
to be eaten during during instruction if
it's out it seems that way after the
Bell so is it eating it at a recess
period when would you eat the food
that's after the Bell um I guess maybe
we're getting into the weeds but I have
three young boys who cannot concentrate
while they are eating I'm just worried
about the consequences on the actual
instructional time but I guess I
probably went a field and this is why
that would be division
to representative
tki
it represent Stringham I was just going
to say that that part of the bill is
somewhat complicated and nuanced which
is why division 2 is handling it um we
had a whole discussion last week on what
it means to have breakfast after the
bell and I don't think we going to get
into it now so I don't think it's worth
my
time represent Stringham yeah I I I
think the fact that you brought up the
questions that you did based on the read
shows the reasons why division 2 needs
to go through all the sections of that
bill I mean we theoretically could do it
we haven't been tasked with do it that's
not what we came in here to do today and
um um you know I I would hope that the
the homework that we laid out last week
would continue and I thank you for your
question to emphasize the importance of
doing
that this point the motion is ought to
pass with amendment I think we're ready
ready boy if I'm never ready do we have
to
vote this is your chance okay this this
is a a vote on House Bill 499 as amended
with Amendment
1650 um motion put forward by
representative hle and seconded by
representative
f um uh representative
Lon
yes representative F yes representative
hle yes uh representative Wier yes
Representative tersi no representative
Stringham says no representative Priest
No and uh uh chairman Mooney yes the
vote being five to three uh with one no
vote the motion passes okay the motion
passes um ought to pass with Amendment
the amendment is again number
165h um as I mentioned this bill is due
out of the Full House finance committee
by 56 May 16
that's my reading
so a lot of good discussion naturally uh
we'll see if division two adds anything
to the conversation or any Amendment and
so forth with regards to the portion
that uh was assigned to them but as for
division three it looks like we have a
position at that point or at this point
I'm going to close the work session on
Senate Bill
499 we'll meet again at 2:00 for work
session on Senate bills 406 and 311
closed
e
okay seeing as though the time is
precisely The Stroke of 2
o'clock we'll start our next work
406 Senate Bill 406 an act making an
appropriation to the dep Department of
Health and Human Services to increase
rates for shelter programs by means of
some
background this bill passed Senate
Health and Human Services committee 5
to0 Senate Finance with Amendment 7 to0
and came from the full Senate again on a
Voice vote we met last week as a
division 3 work session to begin
discussion on Senate Bill
406 at that work session there were
specifics specific questions asked of
kadia fox who has responded to them in
written format it was emailed to us
today but I think um after we'll take
any initial member input we'll have Miss
Fox come up and discuss her letter so
anything from the members to open Senate
Bill
[Music]
good afternoon I'm Kaa Fox I'm the
director of the division for Behavioral
Health and thank you for having me this
afternoon I do realize that um I got the
responses in writing which yay I got
them in writing however you just
received them and may have not had time
to go over them I do have hard copies if
if anybody would like a hard
okay all right so the first question
that was asked was um there was some
discussion about the language around
requiring us to prioritize veterans what
um I can share with you this afternoon
is that the shelter system does a really
good job in serving this particular
population today so this language will
reinforce that emphasis and
prioritization on Veterans and so as you
can see in the response there are um
specific programs and areas that address
the veterans and um those include
specific Outreach and specialized
programs to address this population
along with the training that is
necessary to assist and so we're well
poised to be able to um Implement that
portion of the
bill and we also as you can see we um
have our in our database we are able to
provide the numbers that we're currently
serving in our shelter system and so
there have been 33 individuals who
identifi themselves as veterans who are
Services the next question was um about
not legally present and how are we going
to be able to implement that that is a
very question and it is very difficult
um and as you heard from the shelter
programs last week that there are many
people who do not have identification so
we don't have necessarily the hard proof
weather there here legally or not
however we do not want that to be a
barrier for entry into shelter because
we do know um that shelter is um the
first line of defense in harm reduction
and uh Prevention Services for those
individuals and so again um we know that
there are shelters that work very
closely in their case managers work with
those individuals seeking shelter
services to get them connected to
services and the first thing they need
to do is help them obtain uh um some
type of identification to apply for
those
services and then and um chairman
Edwards had asked about some ideas
around a house resolution that he would
like to put forth and so we know that
the Housing and Urban Development um our
federal funer provides funding for a
variety of different programs however
they do not support our shelter system
so we would like um to see that as a
possibility to have um Federal funding
for what seems to be an ongoing and
potentially increasing issue as we
talked about last week with our um
housing
shortages and then there was a question
about the rate and how do we come to the
rates and so you can see the formula
here we have beds times dollars times
days of the year in the total funding
and frankly as we talked about when we
increase the funding from $8 to $20 we
back into the number of the um dollars
that we have that are appropriated for
these
services and with this bill again it
would increase it to
$27 um per DM or per
bed and those are my responses for what
week okay thank you so
$27 would be the result result of
passage of this bill but the last budget
brought us from $8 per bed to 20 yes
thank you any questions representative
but um chairman wer has I'm sorry
chairman Wier I had notes from before
that there's 950 beds across the state
but I don't have down how many separate
agencies that we keeping track of that
provide these yes there are 13 agencies
that are we fund
um and that are contracted with us of
those the one of them is the New
Hampshire Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence and they have 10
programs under them so you take that you
shelters thank you representative
Stringham I had one other question just
about the nature of the contracts with
the 13 a agencies before and I was
wondering if you have any any
clarification in particular whether the
contract in general anticipates that the
state will pay uh the fair cost and that
the amount is um kind of was done as an
estimate or exactly um you know what
what is the appropriate State portion of
the uh the bed costs of for this
program so I think if I understand your
question we typically do not um there is
no provision that I'm aware of that
requires us to um reimburse the shelter
programs for 100% of their costs and as
they talked about last week they have um
other funding sources which is primarily
fundraising and through grants so um
beyond that uh the state of New
Hampshire is their primary source of
funding at 100% General funds because as
I said they're not eligible for the
federal funding um under um HUD I hope
question um I guess I guess it I guess
it does I mean I know in some other
programs it uh I mean we never guarantee
costs but sometimes the the rate that we
agree to pay is based on some kind of
predetermined understanding of of uh
what is appropriate and we've seen
things that programs have turned out to
be so expensive they've been difficult
for us to continue with after they're in
place for a while so you know I I I'm
just trying to Grapple with how do we
decide you know $8 wasn't enough it
looks like $20 is not enough um and you
know what probably $45 is definitely
enough which is the cost so um you know
it are we deciding on 27 because 2 and a
half million is just as big a bite as we
think is appropriate for this or you
know why are we at 27 so uh that's
that's why some of the questions about
the nature of the contract were were
asked and um I Now understand that's not
IR relevant not there's there's no more
value in in discussing that part of it
uh to help us with this decision so any
other add-ons to that at all um no just
that I think we're getting a pretty good
deal and that we're very fortunate that
we have these shelter programs who are
still willing to put themselves forth
and provide these services and they as
this was a competitive um procurement
they were willing to come forth and so
um we're getting a deal and they're
willing to do it and they're um using
other sources of funding in addition to
what the state can provide and um I will
say though that um this does not grow
the number of beds and we believe that
there's demand that we could um increase
our capacity but we also want to
preserve what we have and ensure that
forward representative hle thank you mam
chair um so in the budget we went from
$8 to 20 which we've discussed in the
midst of an off-budget year level I
guess I'm trying I understand that it
there was a recent RFP that went out and
you have that as data to use to to show
that the there's a huge Delta between
the actual cost per bed per night and
what we're reimbursing them at but in an
off year when we're having trouble in
terms of funding all the other programs
what pushes this one ahead of the pack
so thank you for that question I'm here
to respond to what was put forth to us
this was not um something that we put
forth or requested that it be sponsored
so this came through the legislative
process and the sponsors um not from the
Department follow up then is there any
reason why this couldn't be delayed um
up until next year's budget cycle to be
included at that
point I think that that is a question
that you should answer um and is there
any technical let me is there any
technical reason why it couldn't be
delayed it's a policy decision as
opposed to an implementation decision
absolutely so we can um if you gave us
$500 million we can implement it um but
I do understand that there are a lot of
Demands that are on and pressures right
now um especially in an off-budget Year
and that we're um could be facing a
difficult budget session upcoming so
there' be no guarantee that the
department would be able to embed this
in our budget and have it accepted as a
prioritized
need followup follow up I think I heard
you say 500 million I think you meant
500,000 but please correct me I I was
just being factious over the top
um yes okay the implementation mechanism
would remain the same whether it's $5 or
2.5
million representative
priest thank you madam chairman for
allowing me to uh to acknowledge me and
thank you for being here and for your
recent letter um you mentioned in a
handout that New Hampshire has seen a
52% increase in homelessness from
2022 to
2023 do you have any idea of what 2024
looks
like that is a very good question and
very timely we have have a point in time
count that was taken in January and
those numbers are expected to be
released
momentarily um I I don't have those
numbers and I and um so I would need uh
to go back and be able to provide that
if we have preliminary data um so I I'm
unable to answer that today but I think
just from our experiences in what we're
seeing um for the demand for shelter and
what we're seeing in our cities
communities across the state um I think
we're still there's a lot of need out
there as a followup please follow and
the fact that this is the largest
percentage in the entire country and
it's still growing and it's still a
major problem for all of the major
Hampshire yes I I understand there um
the housing costs in the New England
region are extremely high and have
pushed a lot of people um
into difficult
situations representative
H you we've talked a lot in in division
3 and DHHS relative to matches between
federal and
state is there any similar or analogous
type situation where we do some sort of
Grant to these particular organizations
with some sort of explicit or impli
match where they say for every $2 you
raise privately we'll fund you at a
dollar or whatever is is there any
policies like that in the department
ready so um I would need to defer to
someone else from a department-wide
perspective um typically when we see
those matches as you indicated those are
at the federal level um and the states
Pro uh required to provide a match in
kind or in hard dollar
um in this particular case um these are
are organizations that are small um for
the most part and it would be extremely
difficult for them to be able to do that
so in this circumstance I would find it
um really really challenging and that we
would likely um see um them not to be
able to continue to provide the services
but again um from a department wide
can't think of a situation where we
require
that okay thank you Miss Fox anything
further for her okay oh representative
priest yes I was wondering if you have
any estimates you mention that we're
just funding the 950 beds currently but
it doesn't take into account the
additional people the additional needs
of veterans and families that are
needing this service do you have any
950 that is a great question that I
don't have a response today that's
something I could come back with where
we do have um data from the shelter
programs over um how often they're full
um and when um so from a capacity um
versus utilization you know we could
come back with that number to see where
where the uh difference is and what the
real need would be if we were to expand
those and that might be something for
session okay thank you very much Mr
White or others who are interested in
chiming in on anything that's been said
406 um one thing that does strike me is
the fact that uh this increase was just
provided uh a year
ago and um and here we are looking for
an increase to that so that's something
that should probably should be
considered as we go forward with a
recommendation to full finance
representative Hall yeah given that we
went from $8 to to 20 an increase by 12
and here A year later we're looking for
another $7 increase or they about 60% of
that increase I would move in from study
or itl on this at this point I think
this is a budget year item and it should
be taken up next
either representative Earth I'm willing
do we have a
coin I'll move itl okay the motion's
been made for it is there a second
second okay seconded by representative F
representative
tersi oh do I get to speak
first do is he GNA speak to his motion
or are we good on where it's
at go ahead
yeah that's weird that went off um I'm a
little disappointed to hear a motion of
itl um yeah the um amount was raised
last budget cycle however I think we
heard in testimony that the need is real
the need is um extreme and we have these
different agencies that are um busting
at the seams um families
veterans um men and
women and although it is an off budget
year I think that um the way this bill
is drafted very simply to give these um
agencies that increased assistance at
this time would
be very needed and that next year when
we come back and and write the budget
hopefully we'll be able to um figure out
a way to um match that and give them the
funding that they actually need to
continue those services so I'd be voting
itl representative wer followed by
representative PRI we haven't even had a
year to judge how much help the $20
increase has been over what I wrote down
was a $7 I think we went from 7 to 20
you had eight had eight anybody else
have
eight I had uh eight starting and now at
20 okay but we don't even know the
effects of that over the previous what
has been a year since the budget passed
or less than a year and plus I think
we're being a little bit in this Bill
telling them what we think they should
have for priorities when there's so many
different ones each one has their own
priority each one is organized a little
differently and I'm just grateful
they're doing this and they're raising
the money to do this I don't think we
should step in like a bully and say
we'll tell you what to do when we're not
even providing half and uh as was
pointed earlier a lot of them don't have
identification so we're going to say you
have to prove that you're citizen you
have have to prove that you're a veteran
and you know and I know the veterans are
doing their best to to do special
programs for the veterans so I don't
think I think it's untimely to be
putting all this in now and we don't
you thank you Madame chairman um I will
be voting against this itl being a
resident of the city of Manchester I
have seen personally how the homeless
crisis has been expanding and increasing
every year and I see the number of
people on the streets in the Parks
sleeping and being without beds and
being without services and being without
facilities and it's getting
worse and um this is just a Penance to
what we can do right now to the exist in
agencies that are providing services to
these people and therefore I will be
itl representative
Stringham yeah I I appreciate the
testimony we've heard um you know while
we're we're not uh required to uh
partially fund or fund these at any any
level it is an essential service um that
we need to live in a civil society uh
there's uh many programs that we support
that we gave um significant uh increases
to uh with this budget this being one of
them uh we heard a considerable amount
of testimony that even at these levels
uh that the um uh many of these centers
are having a difficulty uh maintaining
staff or paying them appropriately or uh
and their their skilled labor is making
less than and the the local rate at at
fast food stores and uh there's real
concern that uh that will be dealing
with with a problem with uh this this
particular uh uh need of our
vulnerable uh where where we probably
need to increase beds we might see
decrease beds without uh this
increase uh so um I I intend to support
it based on the test Tony uh that we
heard I do know many of these facilities
I mean I saw an ad for uh families in
transition thanking all the money they
received for people who ran in the
Boston Marathon I think that's great I
don't think that that um uh obviates the
the uh the impact that a $2.5 million
appropriation uh that we make uh could
have on top of that so I'm going to go I
would support support this bill uh that
came out of the Senate uh unanimously
thanks representative Hall thank you
madam chair
um again there are some real needs we've
seen the devastating effects of an an
economy where inflation is significant
cost of food and housing has gone
through the roof those of limited means
took it on the chin because those are
two of the biggest categories that's
that young families in particular and
elderly
are the ones as a percentage of their
overall budget that's the area that got
hit the hardest and unfortunately we
don't capture some of that information
in the
CPI I do think that trying to do this in
an off-budget year is the wrong place
and time um we should in fact plan for
this
this we we just increased this by $12
over over the prior one uh a rather
significant 150% increase over over the
the prior amount and now we're back
again asking for another 60% increase in
this in this category that's a
significant amount I if we had passed
the house bill 1560 we'd have more funds
in the general fund to work with but we
left a significant amount of money in
the education trust fund and that will
limit our ability to do things in the
general fund going forward I'm not sure
who voted there was no roll call votes
on on that bill but I do know that
that's going to handicap what we can do
this year and um this might be the small
price we have to pay to not have the
fund okay thank you all for the uh
discussion I will be supporting
supporting the motion of itl I I too
agree that a jump from $ eight to 20 in
just a year's time uh is not enough time
uh additionally I received a phone call
from a rather prominent citizen on this
bill uh supportive and we spoke and one
thing I did mention is that this summer
of course the Departments are already
putting together their budgets for next
year it doesn't take long before the
next thing you know drafters are at
their desk working and uh it's something
certainly that DHHS should take a look
at for next year when the draft proposal
of a budget is introduced with that I'm
going to ask the clerk to call the role
ready the bill is uh H uh SB 406 the
motion itl by PA seconded by F
representative Leon
yes uh representative F yes
representative Hull yes representative
Wier yes um representative tersi no
representative Stringham says no
representative Priest
No representative or chair chairwoman
Mooney yes uh the vote being 5 to3 uh
the recommendation to the full committee
is
itl okay moving now to work session on
Senate Bill
311 and that's an act relative to
property tax offset for the town of
Hampstead and making an appropriation
therefore this bill by means of some
background was uh approved by Senate
Finance 7 to Zer adopted by the full
Senate on a Voice
vote uh with that I'll open it to
discussion I don't think we have any
additional information uh other than
what was discussed at last week's work
session representative Wier I did uh
talk to uh
commissioner um da
Charlie Arling housee and I said you
were quoted as saying that the state
never made any payments
for property
tax uh to any any town and I said I
think you're wrong I recall the uh
Connecticut Lakes uh Dam things where
they had flood planes that were
um affecting six different towns and
they promised the towns that if you'd
forbid any development in the flood
Plaines because the do dams are going to
put up to save Massachusetts from
flooding we will pay you the um losses
in the property tax that you would have
had and I recall that distinctly because
it it was something that the new
attorney general had to sue the state of
Mass they were supposed to also chip in
and pay these property tax losses to
those six towns and uh they finally did
but in the meantime uh New Hampshire was
paying both the the share by the state
by the state of New Hampshire and the
state of Massachusetts so I think those
are still ongoing and Charlie said well
I didn't know that I'll look it up and
he's hasn't got back to me yet but to
say that this has never happened before
I think is wrong because that was a
perfect example of what it was in your
know loss of property
tax uh was made up by the state and the
state of Massachusetts so I'm in favor
of this and and uh and I think that
there were there were several years that
it was done and not only that but some
of the people in Hampstead say you know
we never would have allowed this in our
town we would have made problems and
made made a big fuss if we weren't at
least going to get paid back for the
property tax law so uh I think we owe it
to the the people that made the deal
initially and that chose Hampstead and
I'm in favor favor of of paying this
you representative priest yes the I
would be in in favor of s SP 311 but the
question that I have is this a one-time
payment or is this going to be
continuing every year it wasn't clear
that I could find thank you thank you
and I would like to call a Mr White up
too I do have a question myself perhaps
that one we can sort of stock these up
so you can answer them all together uh
representative
tarki
okay so my question was sort of related
to representative
pri's at the last work session I
recalled two payments have been made
already to Hamstead so at some point
when you answer my question
representative priest say could you
address just how those came to be thank
you sure um good afternoon members of
the committee Nathan white CFO of
Department of Health and Human Services
the way that the language is crafted
within this bill here this would be a
one-time payment for State fiscal year
2025 which was consistent with the
intent of the Senate um the department
has made two prior payments um via the
governor and executive Council they
weren't technically contracts they were
unencumbered payment requests in the
amounts of approximately 176,000
$177,000 in change
um the reason why we made those payments
is um as representative wer had
indicated there were many conversations
going on during the time um in the fall
of 2021 and the spring of uh 2022 prior
to the the June 8th 2022 acquisition of
Hamstead Hospital whereby the the the
state was agreeing to make those
payments um to offset the the impact to
town is it too premature to ask if this
will be a permanent fixture in the
that I I I think that's one of the
questions that that this committee is is
here addressing today it's it's I mean
ultimately whether the state intends to
continue to make payment to the town in
perpetuity is really I mean it's a
pretty significant policy decision um
the state has done so with the city of
conquer recognizing the loss of parking
um Revenue that they they lose on an
um okay thank you I recall from the
testimony last week uh the town of
Hamstead has had to hire two police
officers uh because of calls and so
forth that have occurred as a result of
um the state hospital now located there
so um I guess you're right making this a
permanent fixture would take a lot of
discussion in terms of uh what exactly
that money year-to year would be
expended on but as was mentioned that's
not really the issue before us what's
before us is approximately
$191,000 to cover their costs and offset
uh significant Personnel changes the
town has had to make to help the state
out any further questions for Mr
White okay with that I'll entertain a
motion on Senate Bill 311 representative
Stringham yes I'll make a motion of a to
pass is there a
second representative f for a second any
discussion starting with representative
Stringham
um while I do agree with with others the
issues of whether to make a permanent
pilot as part of State policy is a
bigger discussion uh I think we should
be very comfortable making this
onetime uh onetime appropriation for the
town of Hampstead uh that's in a very
critical position as we uh reorganize
and and um some of our youth detention
programs and this uh you know the
importance of the facility that they
have uh so uh I think the approp
Corporation is
reasonable um both for us and for the
town and therefore uh I put forward the
motion of a to
you I'll be honest I have some problems
with the precedent that this
sets not because they don't deserve the
tax payment um I'd like like to know
that moving forward if the state is in
this position of acquiring acquiring
property that this discussion would be
part of a deal it seems like in
testimony we heard lots of conversations
happened lots of promises were made
public hearings maybe things were
discussed but no one produced a written
agreement that the state would be
responsible for ongoing tax payments I
understand that's the situation we're in
I think it's sort of unfortunate I think
it was messy and someone dropped the
ball um I do wish to Echo my friend over
there it's not a budget year they could
have come in you know we could have um
maybe seen it I believe the testimony
was the Senate took it out I don't
back refresh my memory to clarify um
during the Senate phase Senate Finance
voted to add it on on an oral vote uh
Voice vote to to to add money into into
the budget for this year and the
department um for the first state fiscal
year 24 the department went through and
went ahead and took General funds to try
to be reflective of that and then we had
conversations with Senator berdel
requesting that a bill be brought
forward to be consistent with that vote
so that we had legislative authorization
to move forward with that consistent
with what was voted on okay so again
conversations that were had as opposed
to actually having it um you know a
concrete deal at the beginning having it
in the budget as a regular ongoing
expense um I think it's unfair to the
town to keep them in this limbo knowing
that next year we're going to have to
come back and fight this battle again
um I will be supporting the motion with
reservations as to how this played out
and the precedent it sets moving forward
known I too will support ought to pass
one detail that has not come up in this
conversation is that this 100 acres in
Hampstead now owned by the state will be
the future home of the Youth Detention
Center yes I'm sure there'll be much
more on this to
come representative Hull thank you madam
chair um we can't fix the past
unfortunately and I fully agree with my
member across the the way that this
should have been addressed in whatever
contractual negotiations that happened I
do think we could amend this to make it
clear that the legislative intent is
this not to go forward because my
biggest concern is not the hund and
whatever thousand doll for the current
hospital it's when we build the sununu
center for another $21 million and now
this this annual payment has blossomed
from 100
70,000 to 350,000 or something I'm going
to be voting no if there was an
amendment that made it really clear that
this was to address a one-time issue
relative to what happened during the
budget cycle and that this is not to be
it okay with that we're ready to call
the rle the motion is ought to pass as a
recommendation to the Full House finance
committee on Senate Bill 311 when the
ready all right uh motion is ought to
pass representative Leon
yes representative F yes Representative
hle no representative Wier yes
representative
tersi yes representative Stringham votes
yes representative priest
yes uh chairwoman Mooney yes the vote
being 7 to one six uh s to one one uh
the motion
passes okay ought to pass recommended to
the Full House Finance Senate Bill 311
anything to close our work session
today Mr
Ripple I have nothing thank you
representative lki thank you very much I
just want
to have a moment of privilege here to
say that what happened with Senate Bill
499 earlier um really distresses me
there are lots of questions about
process that I feel um were not handled
properly I would really like to go back
and look at the tape of the first public
hearing and when we decided we were
going to divide that bill after maybe it
was maybe it happened after the first uh
work session I can't remember but I
believe that we were presented with a
plan for that bill that we all came here
today expecting well some of us
apparently came here expecting a plan
today and it was completely upended
there were members my colleague I didn't
realize represent Mari on division 2 was
here she knows nothing nothing about the
plan for that bill in division 2 I feel
like that was dishonest it was a posted
meeting today that was then half of it
was pulled down without any explanation
and I would just like to publicly
express my disappointment of that how
that whole matter played out thank you
very much for giving me a
noted all
right with that uh we will end our work
session today there is no doubt I will
say no doubt we are taking on very heavy
sensitive issues hunger homelessness
nobody takes these lightly our job is to
uh diligently work as members of house
finance and an off- budget year and uh
review each bill uh to the best of our
abilities with that I'm going to close
the work sessions scheduled for today